[Music]
God Jesus Voldemort Optimus Prime kylo
Ren Falkor Donald Trump what do they all
have in common well they're all
characters humans created to tell
stories and to answer big questions
whether you believe these characters are
real or not is up to you
this is exactly what having a belief
means there is no more evidence that God
exists or that Jesus was his son then
there is that Optimus Prime was a real
talking transforming robot or that
Falkor helped Atreyu stop the nothing in
the neverending story belief is the
question here a leap of faith is what
makes man believe in ideas he would
never accept if they were presented
outside the realm of religion if a
friend told me that LeBron James dunked
from half-court meaning he jumped all
the way from half-court to slam the ball
in the hoop with one jump I would ask
for video of this claim if my brother
told me that he could turn water into
beer I would demand that he do it in
front of me he not just give me some
water down Bud Light and take his word
for it
yet for some reason Jesus walking on
water or Moses talking to a burning bush
or Mohammed riding a winged horse to
heaven are things that were supposed to
take on faith if I told you right now
with all the credit I've gained from you
guys that I rode a winged horse to the
studio today you'd say that I was
totally bonkers and you'd be right
because the truth is that I wrote in on
Falkor who is a winged block dragon this
brings me to atheism the best definition
I've found for atheism is it is not a
denial of God's it is a lack of belief
in God this is an incredibly important
distinction to make an atheist isn't
denying that a god or gods exist an
atheist is just asking for evidence of
such an incredible claim all this really
means is applying the same standard of
belief and pretty much anything else you
do in your life to the biggest questions
of the
universe you don't just believe magical
pictures come out of your television
scientists and engineers created the
correct conditions for your TV to exist
you believe your TV is there and does
what it does because of the evidence
right in front of you you don't just
believe the audio coming out of your
iPhone is magical Apple elves living
inside that thing singing you know that
you downloaded the entire soundtrack to
Dreamgirls and sing it in your room
every night it didn't just magically
appear there the point here is that
believing in something without evidence
is up to you but it shouldn't trump
anyone else's belief in things that are
empirically provable if you find comfort
in believing in god or gods or the
spaghetti monster or whatever else is
out there then that's fine as long as
you don't push your beliefs on or kill
other people who believe in something
else again all the Atheist is saying is
I don't believe without evidence it
reminds me of this quote by the great
Carl Sagan extraordinary claims require
extraordinary evidence hearing that a
guy talked to a burning bush doesn't
prove anything other than that he might
be crazy or took some really great magic
mushrooms if he can prove it well then
we've got a whole other discussion on
our hands interestingly many polls show
that atheists are still one of the least
trusted or liked groups in the United
States while there are signs this is
changing there is still a ton of work
that needs to be done the atheists I
know are generally the most open liberal
decent folks out there I know there is a
push mainly on the left to demonize
atheists as Islamophobes or neo cons but
this is really just nonsense a phobia is
an irrational fear of something it is
not irrational to fear a set of ideas
which would have you killed as a
non-believer atheism also isn't a
political ideology once again it's just
a lack of belief atheists come in all
colors sexualities and nationalities
actually atheism is a great take down of
the barriers that often divide us as
people if we can start at a point in not
believing in ideas until they are proven
to be true then we can start having real
conversations about how to live as
people and to make our world a better
place this isn't to say that at least
from my view that all religion and
belief is bad in and of itself millions
of people have their beliefs and do
charity work care for the less fortunate
or help the needy in the name of their
religion could they do these things
without religion yeah probably but if
that helps them get there and then great
but when your beliefs impede on the
lives of other people I have a problem
with religion my guest this week are two
non believers but as far as I can tell
to pretty decent human beings David
Silverman is the president of the
American atheist and Paul Provenza is a
comedian director and outspoken atheist
we're going to discuss the good the bad
and the ugly about religion and about
atheism itself now if you'll excuse me
I'm going to ride a unicorn to
shangri-la where I'm playing bingo with
Frank Sinatra and Frodo Baggins
[Music]